des croissants à 1 euro dépend au
chocolat à 1 euro 35 mais pour encore
combien de temps dans cette boulangerie
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux les factures
mensuelles ont été multipliées par plus
de 3,5 passant de 2000 euros à 7500
euros le compteur de cette gérantes
dépassant une certaine puissance elle
n'est pas éligible au bouclier
tarifaires elle doit donc faire face
pour l'instant il n'est pas éligible
puisqu'on était des contrats qui sont
au-dessus
donc c'est en train de bouger ça va se
mettre en place et là on attend un petit
peu de voir qu'est-ce qui va se passer
réellement ce qui consomme le plus les
trois fours de cette boulangerie or
impossible pour cette artisan de s'en
passer
même constat à quelques pas chez ce
restaurateur qui emploie 14 salariés
donc on a eu X3 déjà sur le gaz depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine et en
Russie et là on est en train d'essayer
de négocier parce qu'on a des prix
d'électricité qui vont aller fois 6 fois
7 x 8 donc
nous on a aujourd'hui des coûts
d'électricité qui si entre 2005 et 3000
euros par mois entre le gaz électricité
et là demain s'il y a pas de maîtrise on
sera sur du 15 20.000 euros quoi par
mois un coût considérable pour cet
établissement de 800 mètres carrés qui
doit continuer de tourner malgré tout on
mange sur notre trésorerie
on essaye d'économiser comme tout le
monde c'est à dire que on a supprimé des
fours supprimer des chambres froides
décalés on a mis moins de lumière plus
de LED on avance tous les jours on se
lève et on essaye de trouver des
solutions mais on est très inquiets le
gouvernement a annoncé plafonner le prix
du mégawater à 280 euros un soulagement
même s'il faudrait aller encore plus
loin pour ce restaurateur avec un
bouclier tarifaire pour tous un report
du paiement des impôts et des
cotisations à également été annoncé les
professionnels pourront aussi résilier
sans frais leur contrat de fournitures
d'énergie en cas de hausse des prix
prohibitives